hello everybody my name is markiplier  and welcome to the full release of among  the sleep did you finish your drink yes  mama it was disgusting thanks mom only  be a minute mom you just has to make  sure that the cake is perfect we get my  birthday thanks mom I love you so much  mom ah look at me thank you  I think I know a little son chugga  chugga choo choo yeah thanks mom  look what I found wonder what it's a  present why did you go upstairs and find  out hey how much did you have  you only fed me two spoonfuls you didn't  give me enough I'm actually quite hungry  but they owe a pretty krillbite studio  wait a minute what is that get my  birthday thanks mom I'm gonna do some  abacus mathematics this game doesn't  rely on a string quartet oh my back just  how does a guy playing a sousaphone in  my ear hey stupid cow come on I mean I  mean gorgeous you serious